text eval print loop it's a interactive
interpreter which is a play on ripple
which is a standard talkative scientist
so it takes your code emails it prints
it and then gives it back to you but the
difference here is that instead of
printing it instead of a typing in your
computer you text it and then it takes
it back to you so completely computers
are studied in the internet don't need
any software setup you just text it and
you're good to go it was a challenge for
the most ridiculous use of a text API
and I couldn't think of any more
ridiculous things to do texts and
programming with it when you send a text
to my number it will send a request to
my server which I will start so the
server is written no Jess so I'm going
to start the server with no js' I mean -
so that's now started and that's now
listening for requests so when you send
a post request to that server it will go
about interpreting it as a text so I'm a
new user I haven't got an account so I
texted hello just to give it a knock on
the door to let it on there so that text
has gone off to the text services server
which then takes the text and poke does
a post request to it to my service that
X come through and it's picking up as an
user so the server has replied please
sound environment choice and border
persistence that's asking me to set up
my environment so I'm going to set up my
environment as a Haskin environment so
do you have school false has to all be
in a lowercase house called SETI has
more interpreter so it would be
compiling Haskell code and false means
I'm working in a single line environment
you can work in white off of a file so
you can build up variables and work in
multiple lines and do more complex
things but in this case we go something
simple so that's now been accepted so
I'm now set up as user so called set up
accepted come at me bro because my serve
is a bit antagonistic so I can now text
it code so for example I can use it as a
calculator because I some practical use
for it why not
socket exit one plus one because I
really want to wait to find out what one
plus one is all that went really quick
and then send me any craft just send me
the result of what I wanted so we do
it's like more complex if I now text it
map +1 from 0 to 20 which is taking me a
long time so not a practical way to
program for every element in that list
it will add one to it and then it will
return me the result of that which
should be 21 things all with one added
to them so we go that's gone in and it's
got the as you see it's got my input
here and the output here so that has
text me the sort of that phone which
also has my previous result in it for
some reason so yeah there we go I've got
the list of results so I asked for a
list of 0 to 20 so actually give me 21
things and then have added one to each
one of them so it starts from 1 and goes
up to 21 if you've got a language like
me interpreting so for example Python or
Haskell or Ruby you can run an
interactive interpreter so that would be
the Python command the GHC I command the
Ruby command and then in that you get a
single line environment where you can
type in a piece of code and the
interpreter will evaluate it and print
out the result what this does is takes
text from a text and feeds that into an
interpreter and then text back to the
result so it's using the standard
interpreters that you use in your
computer if you develop this way every
day but it's just wrapping them in a
text API which yeah allows you to set
use them by text so you could actually
use this for any command line thing like
for example calcite SoCal say is a fun
that we unix program where you give it a
string and it draws a cow in a ski
saying that string and you can use it
for stuff like that you can use it for
any common arguments I suppose there's
going to be other uses for this system
than what we used it for so far which is
a bit disappointing because again it's
meant to be useless it was originally
made to be completely ludicrous but
unfortunately it's actually ended up
being somewhat useful and I'm blaming
that on the reason that this didn't win
I've cut like for example use case of of
it is if you're a lecturer and you're
teaching a high school class you could
put this number up and you can use it
for the class of interaction or I use
that I'm actually genuinely using it for
now is if you're out and about and you
you've been thinking about cycled I even
got some bit code that's troubling you
and you finally think of something that
oh this might work you can evaluate it
straight away and have a go at it
so as does actually have some valid use
cases it's a bit of a shame that I've
only got limited credit on the text
system or I would use it forever but
yeah so it's not as ridiculous as it at
first seemed I'm currently we're
building some other languages into it
so - Ruby and pearl do work but they're
disabled at moment because they're
unsafe and we'll nuke everything
you say we got it our tweet here all the
bars are available but not as
nice
Daniel purchased a 50 P confectionary it
is very generic